la sécurité vous le savez tous est au
coeur du débat politique parce qu'on a
décidé d'y aller on se remet puisqu'on a
décidé de parler beaucoup politique
aujourd'hui la sécurité on parle des
chiffres de la criminalité qui sont en
baisse on vous la Boo goodie alors
chacun sa tribule le bénéfice du
résultat il y en a qui disent c'est nous
les autres qui disent non c'était nous
qu'on a commencé par exemple oui c'est
eux et je vous ai trouvé la réponse à
tout ça c'est ni les années les autres
c'est des gens qui se protègent beaucoup
beaucoup mieux ah j'ai trouvé des gens
même pour aller voler chez eux ça va pas
être facile il se protège vraiment j'ai
essayé de leur piquer une petite
cuillère et rien à faire et c'est des
gens qui sont retraités institutrices la
dame elle est retraités institutrices et
le monsieur il est retraités prof de gym
et ils habitent dans la banlieue de
Bruxelles mais je crois qu'on pourrait
les trouver aussi en Belgique pour ça
c'est bien la Belgique ils sont rigolos
j'aime bien et j'ai rencontré ces
gens-là grâce à l'émission strip-tease
mission très bien et ben quoi
et donc il se méfie de tout et ils sont
ils sont très partis
un petit peu quand même disons-le de la
sécurité
Monsieur et Madame escott méfie
terriblement de leur semblable il
tremble et consonne chez eux
je suis la bonne et Madame m'a défendu
d'ouvrir il y a pas beaucoup d'espoir de
rentrer on a installé 5 pour blindés
nous refusons l'entrée immédiatement
nous n'apprions jamais sur le déclic de
façon que les gens puissent entre les
gens
ici donc je possède une bombe c'est de
une bombe
neutralisante c'est à dire que si
quelqu'un m'attaque et si je lui tape
dans la figure il ne voit plus il est
vraiment énervé je possède une autre
pompe c'est un sirène et si la personne
qui m'attaque me jette la bombe par
terre qu'elle continue à lancer son cri
de larme alors mon mari a dans la poche
de son imperméable son revolver quand
nous rentrons la voiture mon mari a le
revolver en main je ne vais pas tuer
directement
je veux blesser mais voyez la petite
palette sur le 6 35 possédons dans notre
chambre près sur notre table de nuit un
poignard
aussi une masse c'est-à-dire qu'elle est
extrêmement lourde si nous la lançons
dans les carreaux pour avertir les
voisins ils savent également que nous
serons attaqués ou que nous sommes
attaqués
[Applaudissements]
c'est un sac en crocodile
et j'ai tellement peur qu'on m'agresse
que je ne l'emploi jamais alors voilà il
était intact tel qu'il y a de l'achat
voyez-vous les papiers sont encore
dedans je ne l'emploi vraiment pas je
prends simplement le sac plastique je
mets mon argent et mon porte-monnaie et
mes lunettes dans le plastique et je
m'en vais alors que mon sac reste à la
maison c'est malheureux parce que il est
beau et j'adore les sacs d'accord donc
vous ne sentez qu'avec l'emballage du
sac mais pour la nuit qu'avez-vous prévu
pour que personne ne vous attaque
les questions de ce barricader
convenablement à ce moment là on va
arrêter un peu la porte en plaçant
l'échelle horizontalement en plus de ça
on installe ici d'acheter ce que nous
plaçons
sur le côté et alors pour
sonoriser un petit peu si je peux dire
ce genre d'alarme nous y plaçons encore
des des anciens flacons de fois de
confiture ou bien de café lyophilisé
dans Laura en plus de ça nous avons de
grandes tringles métalliques que nous
plaçons en oblique mais enfin pourquoi
vous êtes comme ça vous a-t-on déjà
attaqué
jour après jour leur propre enfermement
alors le plus étonnant de cette affaire
c'est quand vous allez laisser rentrer
vous aviez le gilet rose comme ça non
j'avais pas le gilet rose mais je me
disais qu'il fallait que je trouve une
astuce pour rentrer et puis comment
savoir trop d'ennuis après alors je ils
m'ont demandé mon nom mon adresse je
leur ai dit je m'appelle Bernard Rapp
j'aurais donné votre adresse et donc
c'est un sésame voilà donc aussi des
fois en vacances comment ils font ces
gens-là alors quand il était parti en
vacances ils vont dans que dans les
hôtels ou les femmes de chambre sont là
depuis longtemps parce qu'ils se méfient
terriblement oui oui et ils ont aussi un
petit appareil qui branche sur la porte
de de la chambre de leur hôtel pour que
si quelqu'un rentre pendant qu'il dorme
que ça foute une alarme et tout ça quoi
sans terrifier ils ont peur de tout ils
sont mais ils sont très émouvants ils
sont très gentils en même temps
le sac emballage
vous rendez compte qu'il y a le monsieur
qui sort de la voiture qui a le flingue
à la mer pendant que la dame ouvre la
porte du garage du merci ça n'existe pas
en France
non mais ça n'existe pas en France
[Musique]